the east african nation of burundi is
yet to administer a single dose of the
covet 19 vaccine
their only protection is social
distancing and hygiene
[Music]
supplies of the jab are so low in uganda
the clinics are turning people away
[Music]
the problem of vaccine inequality still
needs fixing
only 2 percent of people in low-income
countries have received at least one
shot
[Music]
whereas 33 percent of the global
population has already got two doses
in some parts of the world they're
already starting to administer a third
shot
[Music]
welcome i'm ben fazoulen vaccinating the
world isn't easy experts say it's our
best protection but so many people don't
want to believe that until it's too late
in many cases
there's help on its way with the us
donating an extra billion doses the eu
half a billion but that's still not
enough to get everyone on par and really
end this pandemic
for millions around the world life is
back to something like normal
50 000 at a concert in denmark
really what corona
easy to say in a country where 80
percent of people are vaccinated
the scene in afghanistan couldn't be
more different
this desperate man one of many
critically ill
alive only with the help of a fast
diminishing supply of drugs oxygen and
faith
quite how bad things are is impossible
to know as testing here is almost
non-existent
in togo these people are lining up to
protect themselves after the government
introduced a covid19 pass system which
only allows vaccinated people into
certain places
yes if we had not done this i really
wasn't thinking of getting vaccinated
persuading people is only half the
battle when there are just 1.6 million
doses for eight million people
here at rio de janeiro's remembrance
forest they're planting trees for the
dead
it's in memory of my husband who died of
covid in march of last year
it's hard to talk about education
even after half a million lives lost
brazil continues to be a hot spot
just 50 percent of the population have
been vaccinated
in part because of skepticism fueled by
president bolsonaro
including this awkward exchange with the
british prime minister recently
which underlying just how difficult
orchestrating a global response to covet
19 can be
but as the cameras are shuffled out the
brazilian wags his finger in protest
not yet he says
let's talk about that with elizabeth
masuto doctors without borders great to
have you on the show again it's actually
the third time we've talked about
vaccine inequality on this show uh this
far on into the crisis how frustrating
are those figures for you that only two
percent of people in low-income
countries have received one shot
it's very frustrating to see because
this is something that we've been
talking about last spring already the
world has foreseen and that's why the
kovacs facility was put in place to have
yeah to buy vaccines together to
distribute them together but what we've
seen is vaccine nationalism which has
led to this huge inequality and yeah
this will not help end this pandemic
when do you think we will see a
watershed moment when enough of the
world is actually vaccinated that we can
stamp out covert
we have to keep in mind that scientists
are now saying that covert could become
endemic so we have to use the tools that
we have to protect as many people as
possible as quickly as possible because
we have vaccines that are highly
efficient that can save lives protect
people and we have treatments and we
have tests but these are not available
and affordable for everyone so i think
this will be a watershed moment when
there is enough access and we actually
can yeah we can save lives and we can
protect ourselves but not only that also
enough people willing to take them i
mean why is it still so hard
so far into this pandemic to convince
people to get vaccinated if we look at
how many people have been infected more
than 230
million around the world and how many
people have died
over
4.7 million
i mean
those figures are shocking and really
bring home the the
the devastating effects of this pandemic
but people don't seem to care in so many
cases
well obviously from uh from the point of
view of a medical organization we are
saying the vaccine is needed it protects
people can save lives so we are calling
out everybody who can get the shot
please to get vaccinated but yeah the
vaccine hasn't tnc we've seen it here in
germany we've seen it in other rich
nations and yes it is also present in
low and middle-income countries so there
needs to be more information available
and yeah the biggest problem is still
though there's not enough vaccines for
those people who actually want to get
vaccinated so i think these are two
components that that need to be brought
together so vaccines and more
communication and more education about
them as far as the communication and
education goes is this becoming a
pandemic or has it already become a
pandemic of the unvaccinated
we see it in our in our project that we
have yes it is there's not enough
vaccines available and where covert is
spreading we're seeing also the numbers
here in germany it's mostly the
unvaccinated unvaccinated that are being
affected so with this unequal and unfair
distribution of vaccines people in low
and middle income countries are
disproportionately being yeah infected
now with covet 19 and this is something
yeah that should not be happening at
this stage we are still using losing
roughly 10 000 lives per day to this
virus um yeah
at a stage where we have effective
vaccines to protect against it and this
should not be happening on that point an
american journalist was telling me just
yesterday anti-vaxxers on their death
beds are begging doctors in hospitals
for the vaccine but by then of course
it's too late isn't it
yes at that point it is too late we now
have um treatments which yeah and people
in richer countries that have
access to oxygen supply and where there
are enough emergency and
units in hospital available but
obviously these are not available
everywhere so when people don't have the
vaccine and they don't have enough
treatments also available
they can't protect themselves on the one
side and on the other side they also
can't be treated
enough so this is the yeah this is a
vicious cycle and this obviously also
not only affects the people but also
health systems at the as a whole so
elizabeth when do you see
us turning a corner where do you when
when do you see the world cooperating
and
and really getting on top of this crisis
when when do you think it'll be over
basically is the question i want to ask
you
well i hope it will be over soon i can't
name a date because yes we have the
tools there's just not enough political
will that we are seeing at the moment to
actually make this happen as fast as it
needs to happen just as an example
germany has promised now to redistribute
a hundred million doses via the kovacs
facility till the end of the year so far
they have redistributed 5.1 of the
million of those doses so it's a little
it's a little share and we need to get
there faster we need to be there faster
and
obviously redistribution is just one
step when we have more vaccine
production worldwide then there will be
more vaccine available so what we need
now is also technology transfer from
companies like moderna like biotech to
have to actually have more um shots in
the future because as you said in the
beginning countries and now some rich
countries are now just um yeah
vaccinating for a third time exactly so
yes we are ramping up production but we
are also still vaccinating and a lot of
people are still waiting so these two
need to go hand in hand elizabeth masuta
doctors without borders thank you very
much for being on the show
thank you so much
and time for one of your questions now
here's our science correspondent derek
williams
how long do most pandemics last
to make any predictions about how the
covet 19 pandemic could end it makes
sense to look at past pandemics since
since they provide data that could
potentially help us predict
how long the current one might last um
experts trying to do that
tend to focus on the four officially
recognized respiratory disease pandemics
that have occurred in the last hundred
years which were all driven by an old
enemy of humanity
influenza
the most recent one was in 2009 when a
novel flu strain commonly called the
swine flu
swept the globe infecting by some
estimates up to one in five people on
the planet uh top-end guesses say it
might have caused close to 600 000
deaths
in the 14 or so months that that it
raged the swine flu pandemic was shorter
than a flu pandemic in in 1968 often
called the hong kong flu
it was caused by a strain that killed at
least a million people worldwide
possibly many more
all in all it lasted a little less than
two years
a decade before that a strain that
became widely known as the asian flu
killed a similar number of people in in
the late 1950s now what was really
interesting about that pandemic
was that it was the first where vaccines
played a key role it's thought
that their quick development and
distribution uh saved potentially
hundreds of thousands of lives
finally
there was the granddaddy of all modern
flu pandemics the one that devastated
the planet at the end of the first world
war um starting in around 1918.
it's viewed
as the most severe pandemic in recent
history that flu strain infected we
think around a third of the world's
population and killed at least 50
million people over the course of around
three years so
to sum it up
those recent pandemics lasted between
around a year and and three years but
they were of course
caused by flu viruses not coronaviruses
so
so trying to draw parallels with the
current pandemic experts say
is a tenuous move at best
[Music]
you